Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
I just hit 100,000 subscribers and Oh My God
What The Fuck!
I just wanted to make a video to thank all
you guys for being so awesome.
I though about drinking 100 beers in your
honor,
but then promptly slapped myself.
Maybe just ordering some takeout and watching
some Arrow would be more appropriate.
Almost a year ago I started making videos
to find other people to talk about all my
favorite things with.
And as you can see, it's gotten a little out
of hand.
In the best possible way.
Seriously, you should see my coffee bill though.
It's pretty bad.
So while I may have turned into a bit of a
vampire, this has changed my life in the best
possible way.
And I have all you guys to thank for it.
When people ask me how to become a Youtuber,
I just say talk about things that you're really
passionate about.
Find other people that also enjoy those things
and then if there's something that they're
really passionate about, that they want to
talk about,
Make a video about it and Boom!
You're a Youtuber!
Whether you're a new subscriber or you drank
the Kool-Aide a long time ago.
You may have noticed that things change week
to week.
That's just me listening to your feedback
trying to make things better.
That's where things like, The Weekly Sherlock
and all the Ask Emergency Q&A videos and Anime
Club come from.
The next big thing I'm working on is Movie
Night.
The funny thing being that movie night is
technically every night.
Even though that video will only post once
a week.
So thus, Movie Night is born!
A lot of you guys have been asking for video
game videos, book reviews and lots of other
things too.
I love getting your suggestions, thank you
so much.
Please keep sending them to me.
Generally I don't have regrets, but I am sorry
I can't answer everyone's comments all the
time.
I do read everything though.
But I have cranked up the language filters
just a little bit on my comments, just to
reduce the f-bomb related deaths on the channel.
So if you make a comment and you don't see
it on a video.
Don't worry, I still see it on the back-end.
I really hope you guys have been enjoying
the giveaways I've been doing lately as part
of Anime Club
and the upcoming Weekly Giveaway that I'm
going to do as part of Walking Dead.
I might change it up a little bit, I like
doing giveaways more than I like doing contests.
Because it's really just a way for me to give
back to you guys.
A lot of you guys have been asking about T-Shirts
and other swag.
I don't have anything planned yet, but I am
working on some new Channel Art.
You know, making things a little bit shinyer.
So once that happens, I might think about
making T-Shirts.
I have been getting some questions about local
meetups and In Real Life events.
I'm really excited to do stuff like that.
I'm not quite ready yet though.
I'm in the middle of moving Baker Street to
a new location.
I'm looking for a new apartment right now.
So maybe after that.
But I will be at Vidcon this summer giving
away free stuff.
Thank You so much you guys for being so awesome!
I never though this would happen, but I am
so glad that it did!
I am making a Channel Update video later this
week, maybe Thurs or Fri.
So look out for that.
That will explain what my upload schedule
will be through Feb and March, just because
Walking Dead is coming back
and Hannibal Season 2 is coming up.
Right now click here to see my reactions to
Peter Capaldi's new Doctor Who Costume.
Tumblr had a lot of fun with that one.
And click here to get my Series 8 Predictions.
Thank you so much for watching you guys, now
everybody Group High Five!